quatre jours après le crash d'avion qui
a coûté la vie à 10 personnes dans la
région de dever en Russie le comité
d'enquête annonce les résultats des
expertises génétiques effectuées sur les
corps retrouvés
des 10 victimes ont été établies elles
correspondent à la liste des passagers
indiqués
les enquêteurs confirment ainsi la mort
d'eph gay ni Prigogine et de son bras
droit de Mitry outkine qui voyageait à
bord de ce jet privé entre Moscou et
Saint-Pétersbourg pour l'heure aucune
information n'a été donnée sur les
possibles aux causes du crash qui
suscite de nombreuses interrogations à
l'étranger car la mort du chef de Wagner
survient deux mois après sa tentative
avortée de rébellion contre le Kremlin
depuis mercredi des habitants lui rend
hommage sur des hôtels improvisés comme
ici à Moscou signe de la popularité en
Russie du chef paramilitaire dont les
hommes ont été accusés de multiples
exactions et actes de torture notamment
en Syrie au mal i en Ukraine certains
habitants ont du mal à accepter son
décès
chaque jour on a espéré que ce n'était
pas vrai nous fondions beaucoup d'espoir
sur cette personne c'était un homme
courageux il n'a pas seulement dit mais
il a fait beaucoup de choses nous
voulons connaître la vérité nous voulons
savoir qui est derrière cela
la mort d'evini Prigogine pose aussi la
question de l'avenir du groupe
paramilitairei Prigogine réfléchissait à
la possibilité d'une telle situation il
a certainement un successeur et je pense
que les membres de Wagner ne renieront
pas leur principe et vont continuer à
exister
depuis vendredi les milliers de
miliciens de Wagner sont contraints de
prêter serment à la Russie un pas vers
leur intégration dans l'armée régulière